le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais le dessin la
peinture
voilà diverses façons d'exprimer ses
sentiments ses idées sa vie et ses rêves
avec quelques pinceaux et un peu de
peinture on peut se lancer dans la
composition d'une toile mais lorsque
l'on veut exposer son art au plus grand
nombre on se retrouve souvent dans
l'impasse entre coups de location de
salle et qualité des oeuvres on a
parfois besoin d'un coup de main pour y
arriver alors vers qui se tourner
lorsque l'on a envie d'exprimer son art
on en parle maintenant dans les liens
social
le concours Célimène est un concours
réservé aux femmes réunionnaises amateur
d'art et n'ayant jamais exposé de façon
professionnelle une opportunité pour
elle de montrer leur talents et leur
savoir-faire à des professionnels miggie
et lauréate du concours Célimène 2014
pour elle la peinture est une passion
peu importe la structure ou les couleurs
comme Iggy décide de peindre ou de
dessiner il faut qu'elle le fasse une
passion qui a débuté alors qu'elle était
encore à l'école alors j'ai commencé à
dessiner depuis le collège avec l'art
plastique par rapport à une prof que
j'aimais bien
j'avais une bande amie qui était très
fan de tout ce qui dit manga et tout
donc je me suis un peu plongée là dedans
la culture japonaise et tout donc un
moment donné le dessin
vu que ma soeur ma grande sœur elle a
toujours dessiné elle est super douée
donc j'ai voulu faire un peu comme elle
et je me suis lancé dedans donc à chaque
fois que j'en ai envie des petits
moments où je m'ennuie pas je décide
mais cette passion en fait c'est c'est
un défouloir
ben c'est pas vraiment un passe-temps
avec un passe-temps c'est comme si j'en
avais un peu rien à faire ou quand je
m'ennuie c'est vraiment que j'ai envie
de dessiner je prends la peinture je
prends du poids je pense tout ce qui me
passe par la main même si j'ai pas
vraiment les outils qu'il faut et je me
mets à dessiner j'essaie de faire un bon
truc je préfère
la peinture vu que j'aime beaucoup les
couleurs mais comme je sais pas trop
bien marier les couleurs et en fait je
suis plus dans la reproduction mais avec
mon style à moi donc j'essaie de prendre
le tableau vu que ça par exemple c'est
une reproduction donc j'ai essayé de
reprendre le tableau mais de mettre mes
couleurs à moi de voir si je peux faire
rajouter ma touche personnelle
le titre de gagnant du concours donne
toujours des ailes et amen à viser plus
haut pour midi le concours Célimène
réservé aux amateurs n'est pas une fin
en soi bien au contraire son souhait est
de continuer et peut-être concrétiser
ses rêves alors par rapport à ce qui
arrive après le concours
ça me donne envie de continuer
franchement j'ai envie de me mettre bien
dedans ça me fait même espérer que
peut-être un jour je fais beaucoup plus
que ça et non je continue j'aimerais
bien en fait quand tu dans cette voie là
et m'améliorer
pour Nassima Dindar la présidente du
conseil général le concours Célimène qui
fête cette année ses 10 ans est une
manière originale de célébrer la Journée
Internationale de la Femme chaque 8 mars
c'est une initiative qui permet aux
femmes de s'exprimer artistiquement ce
concours permet de célébrer la femme
autrement que par des journées de
sensibilisation sur les violences faites
aux femmes ou autres événements qui ne
traitent pas forcément de la force des
femmes il y a 10 ans quand j'étais élu
président du conseil général je ne
voulais pas qu'on célèbre la femme
seulement sur les violences faites aux
femmes c'est un vrai combat un enjeu que
nous continuons à accompagner mais pour
parler des femmes il fallait aussi
laisser parler les femmes et la
meilleure façon que de laisser c'était
de lancer ce concours pour des artistes
femmes amateurs et ce concours connaît
un grand succès nous avons fêté son
dixième anniversaire en changeant aussi
la vie de ces femmes qui peuvent
s'exprimer qui peuvent exposer qui
peuvent confronter avec des
professionnels également leur art et en
tous les cas leur volonté créatrice et
créative qu'elles ont
le concours Célimène est une initiative
de nassimadin d'art afin que chaque
femme puisse montrer son talent au
travers de l'art c'est également une
réelle occasion de célébrer la femme en
général le concours Célimène rassemble
chaque année plus de 200 participants un
moment unique et une perspective
incroyable pour celle qui souhaite
continuer dans cette voie et peut-être
vivre de leur art
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais